hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to do a
paper chromatography yellow may become a
Tom Murphy is a type of experiment that
can be used to separate mixtures for
example in today's demos will actually
be using different kinds of markers and
highlighters to see the separation of
the different components that are in
those inks mixtures are Cardiff biology
they have found throughout life and this
is another kind of experiment that you
can do to look at the components that
make up a mixture of course it relies on
something pretty important that is the
solubility of water water is often
called the solvent of life that is
because every single chemical reaction
that takes place in living organisms
does so within water water is ubiquitous
with in life and it's the major solvent
that is inside the body so water is the
solvent of life and we can see that
things that are soluble in water like
the inks that we'll use in the paper
chromatography demo because they're
soluble in water water can be used to
separate the components and they name so
let's look at what that looks like
here's how you set up the experiment get
some paper towels coffee filters also
look well and a pencil draw with the
pencil a straight line across the paper
this helps you know that all of your ink
is added to the paper towel at the same
level now here I have three highlighters
and three permit markers I'm going to
take and add a little circle of each ink
it's best to put another piece of paper
below so that ink doesn't stain through
the surface that you're working on
so now we have our names to add it
remember it is three washable
highlighters and three permanent markers
now we're going to add it to the water
so that the water just barely touches
the bottom of the paper towel without
actually touching the ink the water will
wick up through the paper towel and
we'll be able to look at ink solubility
in water and we'll see the ink that is
soluble in water begin to move
so in one experiment we saw two
interesting effects we saw that the
highlighters had pink
it was soluble and why so that when the
water began to wick up through the paper
towel it carried that ink up with it
the permanent markers on the other hand
are made up of an ink that is not
soluble in water therefore even with a
movement of the water the permanent
marker ink did not move I encourage you
to try this at home using different inks
that you can find around your house